From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
We're on.
Today is Thursday, March 14, 2013.
My name is John Dittmer, and I'm here in Pickens, Mississippi with videographer John Bishop to interview Mr. Robert Clark,
the first African American to be elected to the Mississippi House of Representatives in the 20th century.
This interview will become part of the Smithsonian's National Museum of African American History and Culture in Washington, D.C.
Representative Clark, we're delighted to be here today, and we thank you for taking the time to talk with us.
It's a pleasure to have both of you here today.
I usually begin the interview by asking the participants to talk about their family, and I'll do that.
But I'm going to start this one by asking you to talk about this house that we're in now.
I was born in this house.
My father built this house approximately a hundred years ago, and this is the only address that I have ever had.
I've never left this place.
Tell us about the history of the house and the family.
Well, my great-grandparents were slaves on the same property that we own today.
And after slavery, my great-grandfather's former slave master sold him the property.
And it has been in the family ever since.
And when I was growing up, I felt like I wanted to go to Chicago, like everybody else was doing.
I leave Mississippi, but after I graduated from Twest grade, my father, who was living here then, and my mother had deceased, and my older aunt.
My father said, me and sister Annie want to see you.
Well, I got really afraid. I didn't know what they wanted.
So finally, I made my mind up.
I said, Dad, let's go over home and see what your sister wants.
And I drove my boat regular car over there, and we got to the gate.
I thought I was afraid before, but I really was nervous and we're shaking.
So when I walked in, she was standing over the stone.
Now, I really thought some girl had told a story on me and had said I had impregnated her.
Well, I knew that wasn't true.
So my father said, Sister Annie, here's this boy, here's, she said, boy, when you go to school and finish, we want you to come back home and take you to the family of Providence.
Oh, no, not me.
You know, I don't like the country.
You know, I can't stand the field.
I put up a strong argument, but my father and my aunt never said a word.
So finally, when I had the argument all I could, I said, I don't want to, but if you all want me to, I will.
And she said, we do.
And that's how I wound up coming back home and being on this place where, as I said earlier, my great-grandpa was slaves right on this plantation.
This is the plantation where they were slaves.
Did you have brothers and sisters?
Yes, I had one brother and one sister by my father's first marriage.
Then after my mother died, my father married again, and he had another son.
But my sister, you know, saw Fetch to go to big sit in bright light.
She went to California.
Then Chicago, and she followed while I'm up, and she's still living in Las Vegas now.
Oh, wow.
But my brother left home to go to school in Memphis, high school.
Because we had no high school for African Americans then.
High schools was only in the little towns, do right, Alexa, but you had to board to go to school there.
So after my brother went to Yazoo City School for ninth grade, staying with the aunt of ours, he decided to go to Memphis and stay with our uncle of ours.
And go to high school at Booker T. Washington.
So he did, and he never came back home.
So you were the one.
Yes.
Well, I'm going to read you something.
A quote, Jack Bass in his Gordwood to Melanie Nielsen's book about your campaigns for Congress begins with this sentence.
As an 11-year-old Black youth in Holmes County, Robert Clark was jailed with his father, who was arrested on murder charges.
The boy was released the next day.
A white lawyer in the county seat of Lexington defended the father and won an acquittal on the grounds of self-defense.
The year was 1940.
Wow.
Tell us about that.
Well, that is exactly right.
I didn't know anything about what was going on, but we know we had lots of law enforcement officials here, and they not only carried me to jail and locked me up overnight.
But they kept my brother to jail and locked him up, like both of us.
Well, tell us what happened. Why were they out here?
Well, they had found an individual dead about a couple of miles from here, not on our property, but off our property.
And they suspicion that it was my father.
But I was so small and young, and I didn't know what was going on.
So he was acquitted?
Yes.
But you spent, why do you think they put you in jail, too?
Well, they not only put me in jail, my other brother. They put us in jail.
Also, I really think they were just trying to intimidate us, but putting us in jail.
You know, in the 1940s, at that time, I was 12 years old.
Well, I assume that most of the time was somewhat calmer than that, though. Tell us what was like growing up here.
Well, growing up here, we grew up on our own place.
And I can truthfully say, I never worked on a plantation one day in the life.
I never worked in a white man's cotton field one day in the life.
But because we grew up on our own place, lots of blacks, most of the blacks, looked at us as being different.
And I've always told them, I'm no different than you. All of us is one and the same.
You are just as much as I am.
And growing up here, we had to go to school. That was no if and end.
School times may have been four months, five months. It all depends up on how early you got to cut and out of the fence.
The four school would start because the white man did not want the black children on his plantation leaving the cotton field to go to school.
And it all depends on the spring of the year, the temperature. If it got warm, then school closed because you want to feel and you sprouted and you knocked stocks and what have you.
So I grew up with a four to five month school and grammar school.
Where did you go to school? Where was the school?
I went to school, saw this flat. That's three miles this way. How did you get there?
I had to walk there, range sleet of snow. We had to walk. And when my aunt's taught the school west of here, a whole city, which was two and a half mile, we went to school there for two years.
But we had to, we could go through the field and if it didn't rain and get there. But if it rained, we had to go around the road to get there, which was three and a half mile.
But one of the things my mother made sure that range sleet of snow that we never missed a day out of school. And since you ask about that, the white children would be riding buses and they'd come by throwing spitballs out after us.
So I, you know, we get off behind my uncle and aunt who was schoolteaches and I would get a pocket of gravels. And when they would throw those spitballs off after me, then I'd throw those gravels back after them.
But I am proud to say at least two of those individuals have come to my house and have said right here in the same room where we are today asking me for my help to help them.
Yes, I helped them. I didn't hold against them. But I did not to forget to remember. Do you remember when you threw a new spitballs off after me?
But that may have been a little uncomfortable.
They just laughed at all.
Was this a one room school house? Would you have one teacher or more than one teacher?
It was two teachers. Two teachers. Two teachers, eight grade. And that was it. Now that was high school. I mean, that was grammar school.
But after high school, you had to bow it off from home because there was no buses to get African-Americans here in the school.
How far away was the high school from here?
Sixteen miles, Lexington. The next one, 24, Durant. My first year, my uncle became the principal of Mount Olive, vocational, high school. That was north of Lexington.
My ninth grade year, I stayed there in the teacher's home. But his family was multiplying very rapidly. And it wasn't enough room for me to stay there.
So then, my tenth grade year, I enrolled in the Homes Kind of Training School, which is now William Sullivan at Durant.
But every Monday morning, range sleet of snow, I step off of that porch, headed to pickin', just like I'm headed to my car shed, a car port.
Headed to pickin', to kiss that 2am train to get to do rain.
Wow. Range sleet of snow.
You know, that is amazing, but also probably most of the people who did do didn't go to high school, did they?
They didn't go to high school. They did not go.
But your parents really were insisting that you were going to go.
They insisted that I was going to go. And after, you know, when I was 34, or yes, if they had not been to them, I would have dropped out of school.
But after, you know, I had reached that age, I was determined that I was going to get an education.
So here on the... What did you do? Did you have cattle farms?
We had cow, we had hogs, we had chickens, we had turkeys, we had geese, and of course we had the horses and mues, the horses and mues, the polar wagon, and the polar plow.
And I started to make an a full day in the field when I was 7 years old, plowed when I was 7 years old, when I had to reach up for the plow house, over my head.
And I can remember them, they'd always give the young-ish person what they call their old hay.
That's, you know, an old-immune house. And the old house that they gave me when I first started, she didn't walk. She just tried it very fast.
And I can remember one day when I was plowing and the plow hit a stump and the hound went up and hit me under the teeth and knocked me flat on my back.
But one thing I knew, I knew that we had our farm, but I knew I was not going to farm for a living. But when I went to college, my aunts was farming, they had never been married.
I was quick as I'd get out of college, I would come home and take care of that crop for them.
What are the acres that you have here?
It's 228 acres in the family place.
That's a good size.
228 acres in the family place. And I have bought 82 acres surrounding the family place, which was originally all of it was in the family.
But some of it had gotten out of the family by some of the individuals dying and spouses married again and got out of the family.
What was religion very important in your life? Education certainly was.
Religion was very, very important. It was very, very important.
And frankly speaking, I confess Christ at 3.5 years old and the individuals asked my mother,
she said, yes, he knows what he's doing. And I was the truth. My mother had not allowed me to be baptized.
Because that's what I got at 3.5 years old. Have cared me thus far.
Where did you go to church?
A pleasant green. That's a little church about two miles from here. A little wooden church. We're trying to rebuild a brick church.
The only reason we have not rebuilt because my grandfather, when they built the church, you know, the white folk just let them build on their land.
And you know, they built there. But we can't, we have no need to. So we can't rebuild them without these. So we're going to rebuild the church. Pleasant green.
So you said I believe that you didn't have many experiences with whites growing up, that you were not on a plantation, that you were going to separate schools.
Tell us a little bit about what segregation was like in this part of the world. Where did you become aware of that there were two different ways?
Well, my mother always told me and my brother, when we would leave here right on our horse is going to Ebenezer. Every time she would tell us, so now you're all as just as much as those white boys.
She would call their name. She said, but you can't do this, you can't do that. She said, it's not right, but that's the law. And that's what you've got to do.
And I've been knowing, you know, segregation all of my life because since I was large enough, my folk taught me and I had a grandfather, my father's father, who was a slave in Hines County.
And he was 11 years old at emancipation. And he told me about him, living never have worn a palpants until after slavery. He always wore something like our dress or gown.
But when I got, you know, too large for them to carry me to church at night because I'd go to sleep and he was too old to walk to church at night.
And when I was not large enough to go to the field and he was too old to go to the field, then they would leave him at home with me.
But he told me as a child what slavery was like. And he says, young man, things is going to be better. But young men like you is going to have to grow up and make a difference.
So, you had that from the very beginning.
That from the very beginning.
So when you and your brother rode your horses into Ebenezer, what did you find there? What was it found like and what did you have to be careful about?
You had to be careful about that term. You didn't make any infuriate in a white person. You didn't say yes and no to any white person.
You made sure you didn't look at a white lady. If she was coming, you turn your head because they may get upset about you looking at her.
And she always told us.
And we adhere to what she said. And I always knew. And that's one of the problems that we have today.
And that's one of the things I'm going to be spending the rest of my life to work on.
Many African Americans don't know who they are. Some African Americans right now. If a child is smart and and and done well in his books, they'll tell him you're trying to act like you white.
And that's one of the things that we got to get rid of. But this is something I have known all of my life that I was equal to anybody.
Not as smart as anybody, but I'm equal to anybody.
When you finish high school then you decided to go into college and even fewer blacks were going to college at that point.
And you chose Jackson State, which is a good distance from here, still within the state, within a couple hours, dry.
But tell us what it was like your decision to go there and what was Jackson State like and just after we were born?
First of all, let me tell you, my first chance is to glue because I want to be a lawyer. You may have heard of Perry Howard, a pair of Howard, a little north of here between here and here in Evaneza.
And I always want to be a lawyer. And I thought I had to major in pre-law to be a lawyer. And I wanted to enroll a to glue, but I wanted to be a work-age student.
And the to glue told me that it would take me eight years to graduate if I be a work-age student.
So I decided to go to Jackson College. That's where my father had gone and some other folks.
And my uncle wanted me to go to all-come. He was for a long time ago. But I know I didn't want nothing at parliament, so I didn't go to all-come.
So I went over to my aunt's house, one I was telling you about. They gave me, I think, a dollar and a quarter that came back back, went down to my uncle Lewis's house.
That's a grand uncle of mine. And he gave me a dollar and fifth of cents. So I left here, hid it to Jackson College.
It was Jackson College for Negro teachers at that time, with less than five dollars in my pocket. And I left here, walking, walked to pickings.
I walked to pickings, called the bus. The trailway bus. And got rolled into Jackson. Then I called the 10 Length Meals Street bus and rolled out to Jackson College.
So when I got out to Jackson College and I got ready to enroll, I told them I want to be a work-aid. I want to work my way. I don't have any money.
They said, it takes money to go to Jackson State. If you only got no money, call your folks and tell your folks to come get you.
I said, well, my folks don't have a phone. Well, I'll call a neighbor. Well, it's not in my neighbors' have a phone. So they say, we're going to put you up for the night.
But if you only got no money when you get back to Guatemala, you're going to have to go home. All right. All the other students, you know, who went through Russia, and they got the meal ticket.
But I went back to the barracks room 205, where they assigned me. And I stayed there all day. No food.
So the next moment of the other kids was getting up, going to the dining hall. But I got up and went to the rest of the office. And I was sitting there reading the rest of the paper.
When the restaurant came in and the restaurant said, you have any money today? Said, no, sir. Don't.
So we're going to send you down to the president's office. So we went out. They sent me down to Dr. Redrick's office. When I walked into his office, he said, young man, I'm going to stay in you wanting to go to college and don't have no money.
Yes, sir. That's right. Don't you know it? Take money to go to college? I'll say yes, sir. I know that. He said, well, I'll tell you what, young man. You can lead a horse to the water, but you can't make him drink.
He said, now we're going to give you a chance to get an education. But we can't get where we can't make you get one, but we're going to make sure we bump your heads against the wall.
So what he worked out then was to work with the custodians on the yacht for 25 cents an hour. That would pay for half of my tuition.
And the other half, I had a job, a move in the garbage out of the women's dormitories, two women dormitories. And as God would have it to be, you know, I went through that year.
And I participated in basketball. All right, I'm a functional and we just, you know, have followed the dogs all across the woods at night.
And I went out for track and they asked me, what do you run? Well, I didn't know anything about no 220, 440 or anything like that. And I said, track.
I said, what do you run? I said, track. I said that because I didn't want to tell them I didn't know. They said, well, we go shoot what you run.
So then they put me into, you know, start me out and I out ran everybody and everything except the hundred y'all days.
So we got the conference championship that year in track. And then after that year, I was the first person to get a track scholarship in at Jackson State University, a full time track scholarship.
And that's a very interesting story about what you had to go through just to be able to be there.
That's right. What were your favorite subjects? What, you said you wanted to be a lawyer? Was that still your ambition now?
Well, I want to be a lawyer and the dean of students called me in to her office one day. And she pulled her eye glasses off and leaned over.
And she said, young man, I see where you want to be a lawyer. I said, yes, ma'am. And she put her a finger so close to my nostrils until you couldn't get a straightener cat hair between them.
She said, we are not going to let you use the teaching profession to become a lawyer. And if you want to become a lawyer, you pack your doors and get away from here.
And I went back home, went back to the Dombatore and packed my clothes. She said, do it. But they never called me back. And after they didn't call me back a week or so, I packed them and just went on.
But I didn't have anyone to tell me that I could have been a lawyer without majoring in pre-law.
So you decided to become a teacher then?
Yes, sir. I decided to become a teacher because that's all preclared, all in African America do it. That time, Elz and Bina, Jonathan are going to the field.
I see here where you left Jackson States before you actually graduated to teach second grade in Durant. And that you graduated in 1963.
1950.
Before you graduated to teach. Did you need the money or you wanted to?
No, sir. Let me tell you what happened. They had done my junior year. They implemented a program in help.
And physical education. And the dean, Dean HT Sampton, set up a program for five of us. And we could, you know, graduate and get our degree and health and physical education.
But we'll have to go back to school that summer. So it was four men, four male and one lady. And the lady met me on campus one day and said, hey, we're going to have to be here for five years.
That's what you mean we're going to be here for five years. She said, that's what Dean Sampton said.
So I went to Dean Sampton's office. As a dean, I have the grade point average. I have passed all of the tests. And I have done everything.
I have met all of the requirements that you set up. He said, well, clock, I'm sorry. I can't set up a program for one student.
But I can set up a program for five. So when he said that I was going to have to stay there at fifth year, that's when I dropped out of school. She we were in our own quarters.
And that's when I dropped out of school at the end of the fall quarter. And I must have Sullivan where I finished high school.
And she taught me to teach there. So that was the reason that I dropped out. I wasn't going to stay there five years because when you be there, you know, and students that have stayed there.
And when they come back on the campus and see you there, when they come back to basketball game, hey, Grandpa, hey, Grandpa.
But I had not flopped the thing. So you didn't get your degree that I did go back and get my degree there.
And a year later in 1952, a year later, in 1952, one was a Brown versus Board of Education decision that came down to 54.
What was the word around the community then? Was that a lot of publicity nationally about school integration? What was happening here?
The word was segregation now and segregation forever. And that was it. And they did not believe that Brown versus the Board of Education, they did not believe that they was going to have to adhere to it.
And any individual that acted in a manner where they believed in that, those individuals was immediately released.
So the example over in the Delta, when I was teaching school over Louise, where they ate much school. But your first six weeks of two months would be half days.
And then in the spring of the year, your last two months or six weeks would be half days. Because in the fall of the year, they'd be going home to pick cotton.
And in the spring of the year, they'd be going home to go to the field. So when I had taught over Louise for seven years, the superintendent of education sent for me to come to his office.
I went after noon after school and I went to his office and said, yes sir, Mr. Brown, I'm the stand you want to see me. He said, yes, I heard that you said it would be all right for white children and black children to go to school together.
I said, yes sir, Mr. Brown, I did serve that. And I said that the white parent need to explain to that children that is fine. And the black parent need to explain to that children that is fine.
He said, you really believe that, huh? I said, yes sir. He got up, put his hat on, walked out of his office and left me sitting in his office. But at the end of the school time, I got a message that I was no longer needed in the school system.
So just because you said that you were fired. This was a tough time because the next year in 1955, Emmett Till was murdered. Talk about your recollections of that and how you felt.
Well, I knew it was wrong. I don't know the time, and Emmett Till was murdered. I was, you know, a high school official, I don't know, college official also. We were at the fall conference getting ready to workshop.
Father's Southwestern Athletic Conference when he got killed. But I was not a bit surprised. But one of the things, some of the things that happened in Louise, you know, around Louise after I left, I was glad that the prompts that the student time that did find me because some of the things that had happened to some of the other folks.
I had been putting lights and etc. and I was, you know, glad it did not happen to me. But at the same time when that happened to me, there was three gentlemen came to see me.
One gentleman was just a parent. Quite, you wouldn't think he, you know, never said word if you don't say anything to him. The other gentleman had students going to school there and his wife also taught there.
And the other gentleman was a preacher. But he was a non-passon preacher. They came to see me. And at preacher told me, he said, I understand the sumpteen of don't want you. He said, you don't have to go nowhere. You know, he teaching the damn one of his kids.
I said, well, if he doesn't want me, I don't want to stay here. He said, but you ain't teaching his kid. But God put on my heart to go ahead and stay and to not fight it. And I was glad that I did.
Well, I see in the 50s you taught for seven years at the Humphrey's County Training School of Adelta, is that correct?
That was the Humphrey's County Training School of Adelta. And while I was at the Humphrey's County Training School of Adelta, I think a year was 19 and 56, I believe it was, 56, I'll flip to seven.
But when we were getting ready for the baccalaught services, we went into Belzona, Meal, and another black instructor to get a hair trim that night.
And when I got up out of the chair, Rubin Lee took my seat. He was sitting there waiting next. And when we got to the baccalaught services next morning, we had a young lady that lived in Belzona going to have a school.
And she broke the news to us that Rubin Lee had been killed. You know, had been shot about two hours from the barbershop.
And he was shot because he was starting to ask people to register and vote.
Because he was asking people to raise just a vote. And that's why he was shot in Kiev. And it is my understanding that some of the individuals that may have known something about it,
that the bossman gave them money to send them away from here.
And about that time, the citizens council had formed two in opposition to the Brown decision.
What, what, what, what citizens council? Was that a presence in your area where, were, were you aware of what they were doing? Is they tried to interfere in anything that you were doing?
Yes, so I, I very much aware of the, the citizen council was ruling things then. Not the legislature and not the governor, but it was the citizen council ruling thing.
And I happen to see in the, you know, they had the Soviet commission. I happen to see in that report some years later that superintendent of Humphers County reported to the Soviet commission that I have gotten rid of all of the troublemakers.
And I assume I was going to go shove them into what he was talking about. And, and another thing, this is not, you know, not talking about me. My father was a school teacher.
He was fired in the Humphers County because he was teaching voter restoration classes. All right, he went to Madison County and taught at Madison, a, a Rosemaw school principal there for two years.
And then he was fired there and he could not yet a never job in Mississippi. See what they would do, they would take your name and give your name to the Soviet commission, that sovereign commission, which, some of those names to all of the superintendents of education.
We should probably say here that this sovereignty commission was an agency appointed by the state and it was really a secret police wasn't it?
That's right.
And they have files on practically everybody. That's right.
So it was really dangerous to be a teacher and to say anything that went against the white supremacist system.
Well, they, you know, most teachers, lots of teachers, you know, allow their main hood, a person hood to be taken from them.
But never was I going to allow my main hood, my person hood, to be taken from me for a grandpa over over Louise.
When we got our first set of new books in the library, he set word down, I was a sister, Pruspa.
For that is a book in a library with the picture of a black rabbit and a white rabbit on the back of it.
And for me to pull that book and bring it to his office immediately, say if black children see that, they will get the idea that they support the play with white children.
And I sent word back to the student tender.
If you want that day, I'm book pulled, you'll have to come by here and pull it to yourself.
Well, no, I, you know, that's, I guess, that laid up to my termination, which was fine.
So it was just very difficult.
Your father and you and probably others who dared to say what you meant and what you believed were likely to get in trouble in the day.
And I remember my granddad, what I was talking about, when I was small, he'd get up in church and be telling folk about they should race the vote and do this and that and that.
And I see folk walking out. I was about three or four years old.
Old main clogged, going to get somebody keel.
And I was wondering, you know, ain't a white folk here, how do you go know it?
But I didn't know at that time that folk go back and tell white folk everything.
How many commission had black agents?
Oh, yes.
At some point you, when did you go to Michigan State for your masters and talk about what it was like?
No, no.
Okay.
I had been taught all of my life.
And psychology books had taught me that blacks are equal to whites.
You know, ability is not given to raise creed of color.
And most of the blacks at that time was going to Tuskegee.
All right.
And as you said a few minutes ago, lots of was flocking to Indiana.
But I wanted to go to a place where I wanted to make sure to see if I measured up.
If I really was equal.
So I chose three schools.
I chose Michigan State.
I chose Notre Dame.
And I chose the University of California.
The University of California was so far because I didn't have money to get out there.
I'd have to go to Jackson and make loans on the fun of tea I didn't have in my house.
And Notre Dame taught too much religion.
You know, I'm a Christian.
I went to get religion, but religion wasn't what I wanted.
So then that left Michigan State.
So I went to Michigan State.
And I guess we could point out here that there was no place in Mississippi where you could get a message.
There was no place in Mississippi.
I could go to get a master's degree.
I had to leave the state of Mississippi to get the master's degree.
They would pay the state would pay the difference for you to go there and get a degree.
And done my last year at Michigan State.
One of the professors at Jackson State asked me about coming back there.
And I tell him, no, I'm going to go ahead and finish my work at Michigan State.
He said, oh, you think they better than we are.
I said, no, sir, but that's not it.
But I really wanted to see if I made it up to fight for a good night.
I want to say I've been taught that all of my life.
Well, they asked you to teach you in all white school.
Talk about that in the decision you made there.
Mac and I got all of it.
Yeah.
I did Mac and I got all of it.
I was all for the job up there to integrate the system up there.
And he thought that I had better custom to integration and that I could stand it better.
And I first accepted the job.
But after thinking about it, I called and told him that I was not going to accept the job.
And let me tell you about my first class at Michigan State University.
I think class 35.
I was the only African-American in the class.
And the professor asked a question.
I can't remember what the question is.
But I remember that question from maybe my sophomore year at Jackson State.
But I was too nervous to raise my hand.
One guy from West Coast raised his hand.
And I asked the question, I knew he's wrong.
The professor said no.
God from East Coast raised his hand.
And I asked the question, I knew the professor said no.
By that time I learned to shake and hate and I got nervous.
And I answered the question and he said, sir, you're correct.
And from that day on till this one.
I have had no fear.
And that's why it did not book me when I went to the house of representatives,
a home of 22 members of home 21, they're quite.
That's why it did book me one bit.
So it was good that you got away.
Yes sir.
And saw what the competition was like.
That's right.
Then you came back.
You turned down that job.
And from 1961 to 1966, you taught and coached at Lexington High School back in Holmes County.
And that was the period when the Civil Rights Movement really got underway here.
Tell us what you remember about those years, both in terms of your teaching
and in terms of what was going on in the community.
Well, I was teaching during that time.
And I do remember when the milestone 14
had missed my claim sent me uptown that day.
This was when they decided to try to register.
Yeah, when they were side tried to register.
And I might reiterate here that my father and one other man, Black Man,
were the last two names, Black names that they had raised off the books
because they didn't raise their cell.
And then when I found out about the Civil Rights Movement, I really didn't know about it.
And when I first tried to become a part of it, some of the Blacks thought
that the White folk were sending me to spy on them.
And I really got into the movement through Henry and Schoo.
When I went to meet Henry and Schoo and talk to them.
We should probably point out these are the Lorenzies.
These are the White couple who came from the White County in the fall of 1964.
That's right.
And Henry and Schoo accepted me and then they gradually accepted me.
But they thought I was coming for, you know, to get the message and carry back to the White folk.
Well, it was, yeah.
And when you were teaching at that time, were any of your students actively involved?
Did they see the Civil Rights Movement as something they wanted to do?
Oh, yes.
I quite a few students actually involved.
One young man walked out of pitchfilt.
He was one of my football players.
He went down, they punched him in his side.
And he had to mispronounce practice for about two weeks.
And we had, you know, quite a few students that was involved.
We had the Freedom Summer here in 1964, where a lot of students came down from the North.
Many of them were white.
And about 30 of them were in Holmes County.
Do you remember Freedom Summer and the challenge of the Freedom Democratic Party?
Yes, sir.
How do you remember the Freedom Summer?
And the challenge of the Freedom Democratic Party in 1964.
But I was proud to be a part of the challenge in 1968.
And then I, the legislature passed an act,
allowing counters to have an adult to education program.
And I went to my superintendent and asked him,
he would implement an adult education program.
Because our new men of the pound were not able to help their students with the lesson.
And that would be better for the students.
Well, he said, no, I don't think it's in the best interest of the county to do that.
I said, well, may I come before the boy?
He said, you can come and photo-boy, but don't bring no drool.
So I got two individuals to go with me.
I got Mr. Laplace Polk, who was a social science teacher down at Chula,
as Marcial High School now.
I got Mr. Curtis Lodge, who was a social science teacher over at Durant,
which is William Sullivan.
And we went.
And I explained to the board what I wanted.
And the board says, we will have an adult education program when the student tell me, ask for one.
I said, you mean it's a student tell me, ask for one, you will have one.
They say, they say, well, that's correct.
I said, well, next year, you will implement an adult education program,
because I'm the clan of my canister for Sumetinder right now.
So it was needless to say that at the end of the year, I got a message that my contract was not renewed.
I got it again.
All right, then we were the legislature with the incision.
We had two legislators.
Now, I'm running for Sumetinder of Education, but they get a local and private pass.
Now, the local and private, eventually, we, it has been ruled on constitutes.
You can't do it now.
But they draw up legislations like in a county where highway 12 and highway 17 intersects.
May appoint their Sumetinder.
And when they drew that up and got that pass, and I could not run for Sumetinder of Education.
And that's how I ran for the legislature.
I did really interesting.
Before we get to that, there's something I really want to ask you because in 1965,
the Holmes County Schools were forced to desegregate the White Schools.
How did that affect you and your students, and how did that play out over the next couple of years?
Was it successful? Did White students go to White Schools? Did White State?
No White students went to Black schools.
Some of the students had to pay the price, and they had to pay a hell of a price.
One of the things we was talking about last night,
was yesterday evening, planning the further civil rights celebration that we were having,
and we were talking about that.
One young lady that went to school there,
she later went to school to me after I got five when I was teaching over at Saints.
But she said, Mr. Clark, you don't know how cruel it was.
She said, I never will be the same again.
And it really had a heck of a impact on that particularly young lady.
What did she have to face in White School?
Was she just said it was cruel?
And you know, they were not treated like they were human beings.
And I remember over at Durant,
one young lady who lived in a rural area,
Ms. Jarge Clark's daughter,
she was a superintendent of school one day,
and she ate mine from home.
But we gave him all kinds of trouble about just putting that young lady out.
And I don't think he ever did that again.
From 1966 to 1967,
you worked for Dr. Aurelia Mallory as director of all education at Saints' New York College in Lexington.
Tell us about Dr. Mallory and Saints in your time there.
Well, the superintendent, you know, fired me.
Okay, that was good.
It really was the superintendent that was God in God's playing.
Because I wanted an adult education program, right?
When I started working for Dr. Aurelia Mallory,
she had 300 adults coming in six days a week,
four o'clock from Monday, four to nine,
from Monday through Friday.
And then all sevens that come in for vocation,
from nine until Twil.
So when I went over there,
she started me out as the coordinator of the program.
Then within about three months,
I was made director of the program.
So that was God's way of moving me
and putting me in charge of those adults.
And we had adult education programs on Saint-June College campus,
where it saw him at the church in Lexington, Asia.
We had a class in Pickens.
We had a class in West,
and we had a class in Chula also.
And one of the things about that when I ran against Jeppe Love and Warren,
Jeppe Love, one of his challenges was that I had forced signatures.
It's because that's one of my hands on that his name is there.
And I know he can't read and write.
But what Mr. Love did not know that he had gone to adult schools
that I was heading,
and they had taught him how to read and write.
That's wonderful.
And what if we could take a short break here?
There were a lot of political developments going on in the mid-60s.
One of them was Living Johnson's Great Society.
And out of that came the idea of the community action boards,
the cat boards that were supposed to be composed of local people
who would be implementing various government and other programs.
And you were a briefly a member of that cat board in 1966.
Talk about your experience there.
Yes, I was a member of the cat board.
And frankly speaking, that's when we had the first integrated meeting in the county
at the courthouse when we had blacks and whites sitting around the table.
That's when we became a part of Central Mississippi and cooperating.
And we were fortunate to get to white men to sit around the table with us.
But let me get off point a little bit.
You can get the back on point.
But one of the things that I remember most about that,
that night I guess I made about 100 gallons of water with drink and I read Fowlton that night by black folk.
Because they had never been able to drink all red fowls up before.
I never tasted any beer.
So that was the first integrated meeting?
No, I heard that you weren't entirely happy with what the direction of that board is at, true.
I'm not at all happy with the direction way the board going now.
I see the civil rights movement that started in Homes County.
And we always said the cause is more important than any individual.
And we're supposed to be working for the cause and not working for a vice-seer.
We're not supposed to develop an idea and said, I want to do this.
And it's going to be done my way, I know it.
And if individuals cannot reach a compromise,
and frankly speaking, I got a letter draft now that I have not had typed up yet.
That is going to come from me in the Freedom Democratic Party of Homes County.
And it's going to be calling on individuals elected officials in Homes County.
You either do your job, if you can't do your job, then you need to resign.
You need to resign.
And the CAP program, it went well, of a number of years.
First of all, it started out as a social program.
And it started out to get smarter, used to being a way home from Mama.
Before he, she went to school and he wouldn't be a school crying from Mama.
Then it gave individuals jobs who had never had jobs before.
But one of the things I did when I was old at Saints,
was about the Maori had her approval of course.
And I was with Russ College, developed a giant program to have night school for those head start teachers.
Because I wanted those head start teachers to do more than just go there and babysit and play.
But you know, that should have been done statewide.
But it was just done on a small scale.
The great society, the Lyndon Johnson started a particular ally with the head start program.
If I am one thing, I know I am an educator.
It may have been sometimes outside of school, but I know I am an educator.
And head start needs to be a pre-K school.
A pre-K program.
Because children starting to school, first grade, and can't read, don't know as letters.
Here she's starting off behind and they don't always be behind.
They ain't never going to catch up.
Very strong.
You mentioned that you were going to run for County Superintendent and then they made that temporarily,
at least in the pointed office.
So you decided to run for the state legislature.
And I want us to turn to that now because this was a historic event.
And were you approached about running? Did you volunteer?
How did you get into the race?
I volunteered to run. I volunteered to run.
I wasn't an educator.
I had wanted to be all of my life.
And after I could be superintendent, they changed that law.
I ran against them by the spite.
And by this time the voting rights act had been passed and there were a lot of blacks on the voting roles in Holmes County.
But still, there are lots of counties where blacks are in a majority.
And yet that election, you were the only one to win a legislative seat.
How did you campaign? How come you were effective and others were?
Well, one of the things I present myself to individuals in a manner to let them know that I am one of you.
I'm not no big IOU or somebody.
And then the next thing was the strong civil rights movement we had in Holmes County.
And then the next thing was I got a chance to have contact with those 300 plus adults that were coming to the migrant farmer school.
For example, if one was coming in, you know, lead a field and head in there and have a flat.
And he would get there for to be that four o'clock.
And he'd get that five o'clock. And the teachers given in the devil, I would allow the teachers to do it.
I would allow the teachers to do it.
And let's couple of minutes for getting here at all. See, those were poor folks.
And definitely, and definitely, those 300 plus black folks that I got a chance to be the director of, they was a part of the group that put me over.
Plus the fact, the strong civil rights movement that we had.
And mental to pound, when I taught, and let's not tell, mental to pound had heard that children talk about me.
And they knew the kind of person that I was.
You certainly had a strong reputation. Tell us about your opponent and the tactics of that campaign.
Well, I ran as an independent.
I felt why you didn't run as a, you decided you all decided not to run in the Democratic primary, but to run as independence in the fall.
We could not, we could not be members of the Democratic Party.
We could not be members of the Democratic Party.
However, I decided to run once, because the end of the business never been to the pole before.
You know, they may get tired of coming out. So just take it one shot.
So we decided to run as independence.
All right.
J.P. Love and Wilbur Huckel.
They had two representatives from the home kind of before.
But the federal government had intervened and they had to redistrict.
And they had one district.
So J.P. Love and Ed Wilbur Huckel ran against each other.
And the primary.
And J.P. Love warned.
And that's who I met in the general election.
And he's the one that amazed you a few minutes ago that contested the election.
He contested the whole away in front of speaking.
I didn't know until 15 minutes before I was seated that I was going to be seated.
Million right was my lead lawyer.
But he contested all the way.
Were there any tactics of intimidation during that campaign?
Were Blacks free to vote at the poles?
Or were there being questions? We see a lot of that going on now.
You certainly got to vote out. You got to vote out.
In 1967, the Blacks didn't allow other Blacks to be afraid or be intimidated.
Because they were there.
And we had not official poll watches.
But we had watches of God's.
We would call them at every present at every voting place.
And they knew that they was going to be protected if they came to the polls.
And that didn't happen in some other counties.
Pardon? That did not happen in some other counties.
Oh yes.
We're a diminutive.
Yes, yes, I know.
Yes, from voting.
So you won the election.
And it must have been quite a party that night.
Yes, I won the election.
The first night that we had, I mean, the first time I ran in.
I was running behind.
All right.
And Kruger had not come in.
Kruger is the first time.
Kruger and Durant. Kruger.
That's a John and the LaFlau kind of line and a North Western part of Homes County.
Well, I knew the votes I was going to get in Kruger.
I knew those of them.
And I was counting those votes.
And that wasn't enough to put me over.
But Lord and behold, when Durant came in, I won Durant.
And that put me over.
And that's because of you saying you visited.
We call it Junbo Brouche.
Yes.
And all his gang over there.
Really organized.
That's right.
And that's, I was trailing until Durant came in.
And the Durant came in and put me over.
Well, you mentioned that usually you're elected to the legislature and you go in and take your seat.
It wasn't that easy.
It wasn't.
No, sir.
I'll talk about the first day where people were being sworn in.
What do you remember about that?
Well, we went through quite a few lawsuits and Marion Wright was my lead lawyer.
And the first day, I didn't know if I would be seated or not.
Until 15 minutes before I was seated.
When Marion Wright came back on the outside, where I was on the south side of the Capitol, and told me Robert, they have decided to seat you.
And then when I went in, again, because of my experience at Michigan State and Western Michigan University,
the being one black among 121 white, that did not intimidate me at all.
Because I knew what I knew.
And one thing that I knew, what I was going to zero in on, was what I was an expert in, and that was education.
And I knew no one there knew as much about education as I did.
But you had to wait a while.
I think for about eight years, you were the only black in the legislature.
Yes, I was on the black and the legislation when I went in about first day, the regulations of the House walls, you know, you had districts.
And the senior person in that district would choose the seating far, the rest of the members, and here's a her district.
So on this side, where I'm sitting now, that's the door where you come in, right in front of me. That's the door.
All right. And this first line was two seats. All right.
And then I'll come between us, and that's three seats.
So the old gentleman that was the senior of my delegation, he chose this seat for me. This seat for me.
And his seat is crossed our from me. Then the other member from my other district, his seat across the aisle from me.
All right. Now, the vacant seat is far the speaker of the house. When able to speak of the house is not preside.
But the speaker of the house had him another seat moved to the back of the Capitol.
And now that wouldn't burn him. That's John, John. Okay. That's John, John, John, John.
And so you were asked, I said, if that seat, Bob, myself, but out of the point for eight years, the folks from one final set beside me.
Tell us a little bit about those early, well, the first and second terms. Were you excluded from everything?
You were determined that you were going to be a good legislator. How did that work out with all of this?
Well, first of all, I couldn't get the floor to house. If I stand for recognition, somebody to make a motion.
I'm already standing. These poses, you know, Robert Roos of order, but he'd recognize somebody else to cut me out. And I couldn't get the floor.
So one night, this is my first time. I walked out and Bill Monter, you know, Bill Monter, yes.
Very, very outrageous course. Yes. And Bertilemmon, they came out. I had cleaned my desk. I had everything.
And they came out and coming after me and pushed them out of my way. And I reached for my door.
And by that time Bill Monter said, okay, go ahead and do it. You're doing what they want you to do.
You were just ready to walk out. I was ready to walk out. Walk out. And when Bill Monter said, you're doing what they want you to do.
And when he said that, I dropped my hand and walked back in. And when I walked back in on the floor of the house,
man, they was having a hooray. They was whoo-fisland, they was clapping and they was doing everything.
And when I walked back in, they got just a cry.
That's right. But what I did when I first went to the legislature, you know, I had the school and that helped me.
You know, I prepared myself for what legislation was coming up. And what I was going to do,
sometimes I did just like a dinner at Michigan State, a Western Michigan, a Sydney burning midnight hour.
So I would be prepared. And if they did agree with me, they knew that they couldn't share his wrong.
They were at the news when I was talking about it.
How long was it before somebody asked you for your vote?
Maybe about eight years. Really? Maybe about eight years?
That's that long. Yes, sir. And after eight years, we got the group in Jackson elected.
Red Bay.
Group of Black electors are basically enjoying you.
In the state legislation?
Yes, sir. You got three from Jackson elected. They did redistricted and got them re-elected.
But after some of those issues, you know, I would speak out on them, some of the technical issues,
and I could present myself on them. And some of those same elderly white gentlemen that, you know, were the pose to me being seated.
Now, some folks say I was being an unketone for doing it. But sometimes they would know what's going on.
And when time came to vote, they'd be jumping up trying to get my teaching.
And if he's supposed to vote I, I'd tell him I, if he's supposed to vote no, I'd point to my nostrils.
These are your younger colleagues in the Cappuella.
Well, now these are some of the older, older white gentlemen.
I see. So that's a big change.
They're older white gentlemen. That's my summer. Black folk was telling me that, you know, I've been an unketone.
But I didn't do them like they did me.
In particular, I lived somebody come up like the gentleman from Vicksburg, with real sharp.
The gentleman from the Luxe, real sharp, gentleman from Greenville, real sharp.
And if they had something and they didn't know, they looked to me for me to direct them.
But the true feels are never directed one in the wrong manner.
And the first seatmate that I had, his white seatmate, then when it come up, he'd ask me how to vote the vote.
If he's supposed to vote no, I'd say he's supposed to vote no.
And then finally he asked me, he said, I want to ask you one thing.
What you trying to do, get me defeated. That's a what you're talking about.
You tell me to vote one way and you vote another. I said, hey, old man, I'm trying to tell you how to vote, how your vote back home won't you to vote.
Well, about 10 years after you were first elected, you were appointed chairman of the House Education Committee.
How did that happen? I mean, here nobody would talk to you and now you're in the chair of an important committee.
Tell us how, what has happened before that could happen.
All right, that is very interesting. That is very interesting.
When CB Betten Newman was running far, Speaker Pro Tem, ought to fill in far,
when John Junkin got sick, John Junkin was the speaker.
So, Betten Newman met me on the first floor of the Capitol.
I happened following a group, a so-called Libras, my good friend, but they'd all get good appointments and I'd wind up with nothing.
So, Betten Newman asked me and met me on the first floor and he said, I need one more signal to and I will have a majority.
And can I get you to sign it? I said, let me see it and I looked at it and I saw he needed one more.
And I thought about, I was thinking about. All these years, I'm not following my other boys that I've been following and they get it burned and I don't get nothing.
I'm going to look out for myself. So, I saw that I signed it and when I signed it, he dropped to one knee and he said,
who, he dropped to one knee and he kissed that pin that I signed it with.
And he said, who ever thought that white may be on his knee to a nigger?
And I said, let's speak, you Peckaborch, you have to do a lot more of that from Black folks and the future.
And what about you, what was the sacred day?
Betten Newman, Betten Newman. And I signed that.
Then, Betten I became, well, we could communicate. We could communicate to each other, with each other.
And then, after Johnkins died, Betten became Speaker.
I wanted Betten to appoint me as Chairman of Wildlife and Fisheries. He said, no, I got something else for you, better than that.
So, he appointed me Vice Chairman of Education.
All right. President Carter was elected. And George Rogers, who was the child person, he was appointed to President Carter's cabinet.
All right, Aaron Henry was convening the State NAACP Convention in Vicksburg.
And that's in Betten Newman District. He lived in the Queen of County. But his district was Vicksburg.
So, I went, Aaron invited me to be the keynote speaker. And I spoke and I told Black folks,
as time for you to get up and do something for yourself, don't sit around and wait for White folks to be giving you a hand up.
Get up and do something for yourself.
Lord, behold, the next day in the paper and bold headlight, potential Negro chair gives Black Power Speak.
So, I just knew it was all over. So, about 10 days, Betten Newman sent for me to come to his office.
So, when I went to his office, he had three boxes, about that high, sitting on his desk.
And he opened one of the boxes and pulled one of the papers out and said, take that look at that.
I want you to see that. I looked at it.
I said, well, yes, I'm a speaker. I did. I gave the speech. I said it.
He said, what I call you in here to tell you that there ain't no vacancy yet.
But when there is a vacancy, I will approach you.
And that really changed my attitude towards him, with him having the pride to override all those spoken as district and to do that.
That was something that I think is for and that you did what you had to do to become chair of the Education Committee.
And as a result of that, you were responsible for, along with others, for pushing through one of the most important pieces of legislation.
I think a long, long time. And that was the Education Reform Act.
Tell us about William Witter, I think, with Governor Ben. Tell us about that debate and what the act does for a bid for the state.
All right. As we get into that, before that, a white lawyer from Lexington had to call me and tell me what's coming up on the floor and part of it.
I was trying to get on the inside.
I went to the legislature as an education legislator.
And I had been pushing for education, progressive education, first bail introduced when I went to Dr. King's field in Atlanta.
They called a bail up and killed at that date.
All right. Then after Governor William Witter became governor, which was great.
And then he, we worked out a bill with him and we put together a bill, education reform, we call it.
And I would make sure that I would get my bills out first.
You know, the bills come out and be on the calendar, calling to how they come out of the committee.
But the Rouge Committee had the authority at that time to rearrange the bill, the calendar, and they could kick the bill to the Hill of the Committee.
So I met an 82 meeting before we went into the session.
And we got our bill out the first week in the session.
All right. Then they constantly kicked the bill back to the Hill of the Cal.
Kick it back to the Hill of the Cal.
So getting near the end of the session, I got my vice chairman, who was a white person.
And another individual who was a very conservative, but he's a white person, but he's a poser.
And we went to the Speaker's office.
I said, Ms. Speaker, I can't be your office to let you know that I'm going to call this bill, I gave a number to bill, up for a meeting consideration.
He says, I hope you wouldn't do that.
I said, well, the time has arrived, Ms. Speaker, for us to do that.
And he said, some of these boys can't stand the heat.
I said, Mr. Speaker, they ain't supposed to be no boys on the floor of the house.
If there's any boys, they're supposed to go home.
And I shook his hand and I said, I'm going to make the motion.
He says, I'm not going to recognize you.
I said, thank you.
Then my vice chairman said the same thing.
He said, Mr. Speaker, if you don't recognize him, I'm going to make the motion.
So then we went to the Florida House and we began to, you know, convene.
At the proper time I stood it, made the motion.
What does the gentleman from home wish to be recognized for?
Ms. Speaker, the call house bill, such as such a number, up to the top of the calendar for a meeting consideration, rapped together.
You're out of order, you're not recognized.
And then my vice chairman did the same thing.
All right, and he did the same thing to him.
All right, then the house got in search of uproar until they just had to a join.
But during that same time, I was seen letters that one of my colleagues from Cleveland, Mississippi, had brought white colleague,
what we're going to do to your wife and your family if you vote for that bill.
I had seen a letter from one of my colleagues in Yazoo City, what we're going to do to your wife and family.
I had seen a letter from one of my colleagues out in East West Jackson, in Clinton.
That's why he's really from Clinton.
That's what we're going to do to your wife and family.
Now who was writing these letters?
And these were letters to people who were supporting the education?
Let us to people on my committee who were supporting me.
These would be from people back in their home telling them what they're going to do to their family.
But they didn't have no names on them.
So then at the end of that session, I went to Governor William Wattas office.
I said, Governor Wattas, I said, if we can't get some kind of support, I don't know if I can keep on putting my members through this blood bath again.
And he said, what we need to do.
I said, you need to take it to the people.
I said, you need to take it to some of the old line organizations.
Like the Mississippi Southern Baptist, like the Farm Bureau.
And we had that conversation.
And that was the only conversation me and him had.
So when I was a campaigner for Congress, I laid it to.
And I jumped it to go to his meeting.
He was having a Greenville at the Convention and Visitors Bureau.
But I couldn't get within three blocks of their Convention Center.
It was so many folks there.
So after he had those meetings, he summoned six legislators.
Three members of the House.
And three members of the Senate.
Two, they're in the mansion.
Governor's Mansion.
And he says, I'm not calling your here to ask your if I should call a space association.
He said, but I'm calling your here to let your know I'm going to have a press conference.
I'm going to get a date.
And at that time, I will announce if I will call a space association or not.
So that was the essence of that meeting.
So shut up.
Governor Wetter called the space association.
All right.
The speaker, Mr. Speaker.
He summoned the same three legislators, members of the House to the Lieutenant Governor's Office.
And the Lieutenant Governor summoned the same three members of the Senate that had met with the Governor.
And they had a discussion.
And the other discussion was constitutionally.
If he called the session constitutionally, we got to convene.
But the consensus was, among them, we don't have to do anything.
So finally, Mr. Speaker said to me, Mr. Chairman, you might have saw it over there.
What do you got to say about this?
I said, Mr. President, I'm talking about the newman.
Mr. Speaker, I serve at your will in pleasure.
And if you have not removed me when the Governor calls a space association, I'm going to do everything I can to get a bill out of that house, out of the committee and get a pass.
And I turned to the Lieutenant Governor.
I said, Mr. Governor, and she goes, look, might have paid if I sent a bill over there.
And if they know about it over there, but the news media and impede chairs.
So that was it.
And he did not remove me.
And as the bill, that was a section of the bill of what I didn't want in the taxes.
All right.
And then after bills passed both houses, we met in the education committee room.
That's the conference committee.
If you meet on the Senate side, the chairman of Senate Education Committee chair for the House chair chair.
So I was chairing the conference committee room, not meeting.
I call it the order.
So some of the Ellis Bowdron, blind son, but some others he could be.
You know who he is.
He says, Mr. Chairman, gentlemen from one, I suggest that we go around the table and see what parameters we are going to work with then, what we are going to take and what we are not going to take.
And I suggest we start with you.
I hadn't thought about one bit.
I was thinking, I will not accept any taxes that I went on to give my speech.
And he says, what about one sentence?
I think I will not accept any taxes.
What about one half percent?
I think the gentleman from one very smart.
I think he knows one half is taxes.
Then I realized what I had done.
I had put myself into a jail.
So we stayed tied up for three weeks.
They were trying to kill a bill.
Now, Mr. Speaker, first time he ever did this, he put the chairman of ways of means on that because it was money.
He always do that.
Okay, that's good.
But then he put somebody on there who was opposed to it.
That's the gentleman from Grenada.
So he was trying to stack the committee on us.
So after we had met and met and met for three weeks, then Mr. Speaker, Betany Newman, says,
when you meet a long time on legislation like Betany,
it has a tendency to kill it.
If you want your old bad bill, you better go ahead and try to work somewhere to get it out.
But what I did not do, what I did, I still helped out for no taxes.
But I got with one of the senators.
And I worked out a plane with one of the senators.
And let the senator present that to the committee, to the committee.
And let the senator give us speech on that, like he is talking to me.
Now, I didn't work this out, I didn't give it to the senator.
Now, why didn't you want taxes?
I mean, this is a program.
Pardon?
Why didn't you want to raise taxes?
Well, at that time, I felt that we had the money to do it.
And taxes were just a way to kill it.
And if we were, you know, money for everything else, why we can't have money for education?
No, no, no.
What that bill did when it became law?
Well, it compulsed the school of talents.
Now, that bill had been repealed around the time of the Brown decision.
It was that law.
They were used to be compulsory incentives.
Yes, sir.
And then school and immigration came along.
And so, so there was, Mississippi, I think, was the only state in union without a compulsory attendance.
There was all the state and the nice without a compulsory school law.
We were the, maybe the first state to pass one and the first state to repeal it.
I think we first passed one in 1924 if my memory served me correctly.
And what else did the new bill do?
Early childhood education.
So it was kindergarten?
Yeah, kindergarten.
It was a bill that, well, you told us how difficult it was to get fast.
But just tremendously important in terms of where the state was going.
And as the education person on the committee in the legislature, why you were instrumental in many of it happened?
Well, yes, sir.
You know, it was my, my teaching.
I had not, for example, one time before Governor Winter.
They would, as the education committee, third of one, individuals.
I was not chairman then.
And they would get up and leave so to make sure we wouldn't have a majority.
But what I did, I had my individuals, some in the cloakroom, some in the closet, some in the bathroom.
And they were counting.
And when they got up and left, I went knocked on the doors.
And I knocked on the door.
They came back and we had a majority.
And I moved that we would bring the bills to the top of the calendar for immediate consideration.
I was not chairman then.
Somebody else was chairman for immediate consideration.
And they looked around and said, well, you got them a job.
They just go, how to carry it.
So we got it out of the committee.
And that was it.
But one end of the day, you came back to the committee room the other day.
When he found out that Bill had been called, he got up on that table.
And he walked down that table, stonking and excreming.
That's because that bill had been brought out of the committee.
Well, thank you so much for going into this detail.
This is important for this door, it's a record.
We've kept you long enough, but I can't let you go without asking you about your two campaigns for Congress,
or the U.S. House of Representatives.
What made you decide to run for Congress and talk us a little bit about those campaigns?
Well, the reason I decided to run for Congress, I wanted to direct,
I want to direct, why shouldn't I attention away from the way it had been directed down through the year?
For example, you go through Louisiana and Texas, and you can see those plants and et cetera there,
that were built by the federal government.
And I was going to be further farmers.
I was going to fight for the farmers, but I was not going to go with the mentality that nothing can come to the Delta that will hinder farmers.
And it should point out that Delta planters have historically had a lot of political power.
They had political power, the most political two of my friends.
I got a chance to meet both of them, and campaign on the stump with some of John Stendon's native too.
And they both was my friend, Jim Eastland, I got to know him, he was my friend.
I think people, because of what has happened, it's hard for people to realize that when you were running for Congress back then,
there were a lot of important Democrats elected to office that they supported you.
Yes, sir.
And when I ran for office, we did not have the districts that we have now.
My district ran from down in Port Gibson all the way over to Wefster County, all the way up and over to Wefster County.
And then even with that district, another thing that we found out when we did a study of the election,
if we had had poll watches at other places, at say, another places we would have won.
I've been talking about the racial tactics in that campaign.
You tell us about your opponents and how he campaigned.
Web Franklin, who was...
Well, Wef campaigned, he had a lot of money to campaign.
I had just enough to get it out, but, you know, way up so far as I'm concerned, I'm the kind of individual that we can have different philosophies and we can disagree and I don't follow with you and get angry with you.
And, you know, a lot of folks did not turn out in some areas.
And some areas, well, frankly speaking right here in the Holmes County, down in the Bay of the Civil Rights Movement, I didn't get to turn out down there.
Was that because of the Eddie Carthane?
Yes, yes, yes.
Carthane was a mayor of Chula and he was accused of a number of crimes.
Yes.
And how did that play out into the election then?
Well, it played out into the election that I was not coming down and put my arms around him.
And essentially saying, you know, let the court system operate.
Yes, that's right.
That's right.
There was some folks who didn't like that.
Did you think that cost you the election?
That cost me the election.
If the Mausdom had turned out the way they have turned out for me every other time I've run, I would have won.
Got far to 9% plus, that's then get 50% plus.
Did you think you were going to win?
Way say.
Did you think you were going to win an election thing?
I wasn't sure. I know was.
I was always, you know, curious. I wasn't sure.
Well, this is a much interactive national attention.
You were very charitable with Mr. Franklin, but I just found one of this campaigns of the slogan.
You left Web Franklin, he's one of us.
Now what does that mean?
Well, that's playing, that's racism.
That's racism playing to the White Pope.
I think another one is, do you know who I'm running against that was another of us?
Well, that's another one.
But like I have, you know, that will fight folks.
And I work with them.
All right, when I first ran for attempted to run for Speaker Pro Temporal and Mississippi legislature,
I did not run because there was some African Americans who was not going to vote for me.
I didn't want that grand cheer and saying, grand mama, grand data.
Why you didn't vote for that black man?
But the second time around, you know, I said, I am going to run.
I'm begging you for your support and pleading with you for your support.
If you don't support me, I'm running anyway.
So out of 35 African Americans, I got 17 of the votes.
But I got 87% of the total vote of the Mississippi House of Representatives.
And I got those votes, those men and women, knew that I was black.
And they saw that I was black.
But they voted for me as a person, and not as a white person, and not as a black person.
And you would establish yourself, your credentials, and they respected you.
That's right.
And the other time I was chairman of the Speaker Pro Temporal,
there was times when they tried to get me to spin in the rear.
So I was, I saw the physical fails of how.
If you put the money in the budget, we're spinning.
But if you don't put the money in the budget,
we will not spin it.
Just a quick word about your second campaign.
You came so close in the first campaign for the House.
Two years later, you ran against Franklin again.
What was different in that campaign and talked a little bit about how that went down?
Well, the campaigns went very much the same.
The second campaign that we were, you know, we were better organized,
and we knew more about what we were doing.
But the two campaigns went very much the same.
There were several other farmers in the Delta that, you know, tried to support me
and tried to get the rest of the farmers to support me.
But if the farmers of the Delta had supported me,
I would have worn particularly the second election.
I remember that election.
And some of us were thinking that what was working against you,
was they identified you as being with the Civil Rights Movement as part of the Civil Rights Movement.
Yes, and then when you did have a Black candidate eventually winning my guest beat,
why he was not identified with the Civil Rights Movement.
Well, one of the things that asked us though, we had changed the district.
We had changed the district when they asked for ran.
Much larger Black district.
Yeah, we had changed the population.
The percentage of population was larger.
We had really given him a winnable district.
You see, I'd really, so far as if you're going to take Mississippi, black and white as it was then,
with my district running all up into Warnona and Owlin into Wefster County.
Well, they had Jerry mandered that as soon as it looked like Blacks were going to vote.
So this would not be an overwhelmingly black district.
Then they made it an overwhelmingly black district.
And of course, that made it more difficult for Democrats to win another district.
That's right.
This is what we're dealing with now.
Well, I was going to point out that after that, you came back and you continued to serve with distinction in the legislature.
In 1992, you elected Speaker Pro-Kam of the House.
And in 2000, there were 35 black representatives in the Mississippi legislature.
And that represents some progress at least.
But before we let you go, one thing we haven't talked about is your family.
Tell us about your family.
Well, whether you want Minnesota.
Well, I mean, you were married in 1971 and you had...
Yes, I didn't get married until I think I was 38 years old.
I had real family here, my sister's children, and helped to educate them.
And they're done well today.
As I said, my nephew that I've raised here, he is a cardiologist specialist.
He's a cardiologist in California.
And he was the youngest cardiologist at the time when he graduated from the University of Michigan.
And my great-grandpa was slaves here.
And they bought the place.
And my grandparent was here.
And my grandparent, as well as my parent, always taught me that I was somebody.
And my education was important.
And you taught your children the same thing?
And I taught my children the same thing.
For example, you know, that's my wife's first wife's photo up there.
Sometimes it'd be two dozen little bars out there.
They'd be playing with different equipment that they had.
But I had them to know that you are not anymore.
And they would be playing in those little boys out there.
But once they grow up, they go one way.
And hopefully you're going to go another way.
But I tell them not, if you go the way I want you to go, I'm going to stick with you.
But now, if you go the way, you want to go, and they're going to write the right answer.
You can be sitting on the big, stockpots that ever needs it.
I weigh that.
But you go have to get out and take care of your own if you don't.
And they both did it.
And they both are lawyers.
You have been on the scene for a long time.
The final question that I'm asking most of the people that we are interviewing
is one of the best and most positive changes that they can place in the state during your lifetime.
So what pressing problems remain to be solved?
I'm hesitating, hesitating not because, like a word.
But the main problem I see in the state of Mississippi right now,
we need to eradicate political parties because we have government now by the party and by the party and not for the people.
And you have government now.
If this party is far, and it's like that in Washington, this one going to be against it and vice versa.
And our political parties, as I see it, and I have a right to believe in what I believe in because I have been out there.
Our political parties are the greatest hindrances in the state of Mississippi today.
It's sort of like there's a Washington.
There's like it is in Washington.
But if the Democrats want it, then they're going to make Democrats look good, we ain't no beefy.
If the Republicans want it, we ain't no beefy.
What's the biggest positive change in the state in the state?
Well, the biggest positive change that I've taken place in the state is that, you know, people are free,
having much change taking place really, since the civil rights movement, people are free to go where they want to go,
go in the other place they want to eat and go to any motel you want to in the state.
But the civil rights movement was great.
It was great.
We couldn't have been where we are today without the civil rights movement.
But I'm afraid, and I'm working on it right now, that if we don't do something, history is going to record that for lack of leadership in Mississippi, all of the good works of the civil rights movement die.
And I'm working on that right now.
Well, that is probably a good way to end that representative Clark has spent his whole life in public service, and he's not through yet.
Thank you again for giving it your time.
This has been a splendid time for us.
Thank you, thank you, thank you very much.
Oh, I was.
This has been a presentation of the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.